COULD SEE MORE U.S. TROOPS
HEADED EAST.
BRIANNA?
>> BARBARA, WE KNOW YOU'LL BE
WATCHING.
THANK YOU.
>>> ALL RIGHT, JOINING US NOW
RETIRED MAJOR GENERAL JAMES
"SPIDER" MARKS, HEAD OF
GEOPOLITICAL STRATEGY AT ACADEMY
SECURITY.
SPIDER, THIS IS THE MAP WE HAVE
BEEN LOOKING AT FOR DAYS,
190,000 RUSSIAN TROOPS RINGING
UKRAINE.
THERE'S REALLY A NEW FOCUS THIS
MORNING.
>> THERE REALLY IS.
HERE IS WHERE LUHANSK AND DONBAS
REGION WE HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT.
WHAT WE ANTICIPATE AND WHAT
PUTIN SAID HE IS GOING TO DO, HE
IS NOW GOING TO BRING ADDITIONAL
FORCES INTO THIS AREA.
BEAR IN MIND, THEY'VE BEEN IN
THERE SINCE 2014.
THIS COULD BE AN INVASION
WITHOUT A SHOT BEING FIRED.
>> THE NEXT FEW HOURS WILL TELL
US A LOT.
THIS AREA IS THE AREA THAT THE
RUSSIANS ALREADY MORE OR LESS
CONTROL.
THE RUSSIAN-BACKED SEPARATISTS
ALREADY CONTROL.
BUT THEY CLAIM THIS ENTIRE AREA
HERE.
WHAT ARE YOU WATCHING FOR?
>> EXACTLY.
THE INITIAL MOVE, THIS IS AGAIN
AS YOU INDICATED, THIS IS WHERE
THE SEPARATISTS HAVE BEEN FOR
THE LAST EIGHT, SEVEN YEARS.
THIS REGION IS WHAT PUTIN HAS
SAID HAS ALWAYS BEEN
HISTORICALLY RUSSIAN.
IT WAS TAKEN FROM HIM, FALL OF
SOVIET UNION, ET CETERA, ET
CETERA.
WE HAVE THE HISTORY.
THE BIG CONCERN I SEE IS NOT
ONLY A MOVE INTO THIS AREA, BUT
ALSO THE POTENTIAL FOR A MOVE
DOWN TO, COULD HAPPEN, THIS IS
THE NEPER RIVER.
I CAN SEE WHERE HE WOULD BE
ENTHUSIASTIC, LOOK AT THIS MAP,
HE WOULD BE ENTHUSIASTIC OF
ACHIEVING THIS KIND OF BITE.
I'M NOT CERTAIN HOW THE WORLD
WOULD RESPOND TO IT?
>> HOW WOULD HE DO IT
MILITARILY?
>> NOT HARD AT ALL.
HE HAS FORCES IN CRIMEA, ATTACK
HELICOPTERS, FIGHTERS.
HE ALSO HAS NAVAL PRESENCE HERE,
THE SEA OF A SOLVE, HE HAS JOINT
AND COMBINED CAPABILITY TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT WERE THIS TO BE
A DECISION OF INVASION.
HE HAS THE CAPABILITY.
>> THIS IS ANOTHER AREA WHERE
YOU CAN PUSH IN HERE.
WHAT CAN UKRAINIANS DO ABOUT
THIS?
>> THE UKRAINIANS OBVIOUSLY LOOK
AT A MAP IN DETAIL, THE
UKRAINIANS HAVE FORCES THAT ARE
IN THIS AREA.
THIS IS THE SEPARATION LINE.
SO THERE'S BEEN FIGHTING ACROSS
THIS LINE, BUT THIS IS
CONTROLLED BY RUSSIAN FORCES AND
SEPARATISTS.
THE UKRAINIANS ARE THROUGHOUT
THIS AREA.
IF PUTIN WAS TO PUSH LIKE THIS,
OR JUST SIMPLY IN THIS AREA, HE
IS GOING TO FACE UKRAINIAN
FORCES.
THIS IS WHERE A FIGHT WILL
OCCUR.
>> AND AGAIN, I WANT PEOPLE TO
KNOW.
THIS IS WHERE THEY ARE RIGHT
NOW.
THE NEXT STAGE WOULD BE HERE,
THE AREAS OF SEPARATISTS CLAIM.
ANOTHER STAGE WOULD BE TRYING TO
CONNECT IT WITH CRIMEA HERE.
THESE ARE THE DIFFERENT STAGES.
I WANT TO PULL OUT TO THE
OVERALL SITUATION HERE.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT A LARGE SCALE
INVASION OF UKRAINE, WHAT WOULD
THAT BE?
>> WELL, A LARGE SCALE INVASION
COULD TAKE PLACE, BUT BEAR IN
MIND, IN MY MIND, THAT IS NOT A
POSSIBILITY THAT EXISTS RIGHT
NOW.
HE HAS ABOUT 200 -- LET'S SAY
200,000 FORCES HERE.
IN ORDER TO OCCUPY AND CONTROL
UKRAINE IT WOULD TAKE CLOSE TO
ABOUT 800,000 FORCES.
HOWEVER, IF HE WAS GOING TO MOVE
IN THE DIRECTION OF KYIV, HE
COULD DO THAT THIS WAY.
AND THEN HE HAS FORCES HERE.
THESE WOULD BE ALLOCATED TO
OPERATIONS HERE.
BUT HE'S GOT THIS CAPABILITY.
SO YOU HAVE THE CLASSIC PENCER
MOVEMENT.
BUT IF YOU MOVED INTO KYIV,
THAT'S A 3 MILLION PERSON CITY.
YOU WOULD CAUSE AN INCREDIBLE
AMOUNT OF RUBBLE AND HAVE TO
CONTROL IT.
AND ULTIMATELY HE WOULD HAVE TO
REBUILD IT.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE ECONOMY TO
DO THAT.
>> AGAIN SO PEOPLE KNOW THIS.
THIS IS WHERE WE ARE NOW.
THIS IS WHERE THE SITUATION IS
NOW.
THAT'S WHAT TO WATCH THE NEXT
FEW DAYS.
IF THE GOAL ISN'T THE ENTIRE
NATION AND OCCUPATION OF THE
ENTIRE NATION, WHAT ARE ALL
THESE OTHER TROOPS, ALL HE'S
TALKING ABOUT THIS AREA DOWN
HERE, WHY THESE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF FORCES?
>> THIS CAUSES PAUSE.
THIS IS WHAT WE CALL A HEAD
FAKE.
WE'RE PAYING ATTENTION TO THIS.
PUTIN AND LUASHENKO WERE UP
HERE EXERCISES HERE.
THESE FORCES ARE OUT OF THEIR
GARRISON LOCATIONS, IN THE
FIELD, DOING WHAT SOLDIERS AND
MILITARY FOLKS GET PAID TO DO.
ENHANCE THEIR READINESS.
YOU HAVE THIS INCREDIBLE SHADOW
THAT'S BEEN CAST OVER UKRAINE.
I WOULD SAY LONG TERM PUTIN
WANTS TO CONTROL UKRAINE AND
HE'S DOING IT IN BITE-SIZE
CHUNKS.
HE'S TAKING A LONGER VIEW.
HE'LL BE AROUND FOR ANOTHER 20
YEARS, RIGHT?
THIS IS -- HERE WAS STEP ONE.
HERE IS STEP TWO.
STEP THREE MAY BE THIS.
AND HE STARTS TO INVALIDATE THE
CREDIBILITY OF ZELENSKYY AND THE
GOVERNMENT.
>> JUST SO PEOPLE SEE THE
OVERALL LARGER MAP OF EUROPE,
JIM WAS TALKING ABOUT ESTONIA
AND THE BALTIC STATES.
POLAND IS RIGHT HERE.
THERE IS CONCERN IN TERMS OF
OTHER EUROPEAN NATIONS THAT ARE
ALLIES.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WHEN PUTIN LOOKS AT THIS, HE
SEES THIS ENCROACHMENT OF NATO
THE EAST, RIGHT?
FROM 1999 UNTIL TODAY, THOSE
NATO NATIONS HAVE GONE FROM 16